you also talk in your book about ways
that men can keep their prostate healthy
which is very important now we're
talking three things can go wrong with
the prostate and the first is
enlargement it can increase as men age
typically in your demographic it can
also become in place talking about where
our young guys and obviously prostate
cancer so one of the things that
maximizes our optimizes prostate health
is prostate massage or milking of the
prostate so I wanted to show you it does
sound a little bit invasive but it is an
important and part of prostate health
and also can be erotic and arousing to
men by the way so it's not only done by
your urologist it also could be part of
your your sexual play with your spouse's
I might have to watch a lot of milking
should be in sexual play stimulate this
is the male g-spot okay no not in a
condom yeah so wait so this is you know
a metaphor for what the prostate is so
it feels it's the size of a walnut if
it's normal-sized hopefully yours is and
it feels sort of like the end of your
nose if you want like a cartilage sort
of rubbery round area that's accessed
okay back to wait oh okay accessed
rectally I think I understand what
you're talking about
and you're saying that a man should
massage that area you can't do it to
yourself you need a masseuse you need to
have a happy ending I guess if you can
find that but it's better if it's done
medically or as part of your sexual
repertoire with your with your what if
your prostate is 0.03 hello
your PSA oh yeah okay so you thought
that means you are at low risk for
prostate cancer but I think you would
still benefit from this maybe just for
me about that
that'll be a hard sell though yeah I
think you have a different generation
because this is really important to know
that because what happens is is that
there are calcifications that can build
up in the prostate that can lead to
prostate cancer so you're gonna have to
stimulate the prostate or frequent
sexual intercourse or masturbation well
that were good yeah that's not happening
is the same for women with their
prostate well women don't have a
prostate what but they they they do have
glands you know that are the homolog or
the vestigial remnant of a prostate and
they are important for female
ejaculation but that's a dip we'll talk
about that on another the next time
online I don't want ya okay now what you
see a lot of men come to you for help
what do they complain about the most
what is their biggest complaint sexually
it men have I think aside from erectile
dysfunction which seems to be pandemic
here in most
I feel like it is because you are the
demographic saying that what are you
talking about happens in mid to late 40s
early start to experience signs of male
menopause right will be the signs of
male menopause the beginning of the
inability to attain or sustain and
erection right satisfactory for sexual
relations right
every time the man I have giant breasts
now does that also low libido or
decreases good send that that way yeah
we're completely out of time I'm sorry
we're so far out of time this ended
prematurely
I think we've milked this subject
[Applause]
I blame him in his point O three secrets
of the sexually satisfied woman and the
doctors airs weekdays check your local
listings and we have so much more to
talk about so please do come back and
bring more crazy and I want that pipe oh
here it is I'm in love all right got the
Jennifer Berman and we'll be right back
you